hello victor how are you
how's it going i'm great how are you
i'm great i i just feel great to host
you today
so yeah thanks for having me um it's
gonna be fun
so victor is a researcher at hugging
face and he's the co-author of the paper
that we are going to discuss he's
actually the first author so that's
pretty cool
yeah
would you like to introduce yourself a
little
yeah so i'm victor um i'm a researcher
like part of the science team at dragon
face
um and the paper we're going to discuss
today um was
done as part of big science so this one
year long research endeavor
uh who'd go is like to train a very
large multilingual um
to produce a very large multilingual
data set and train a very large language
model on on top of these data sets
um and so this
this paper is kind of like the
the first output of one of the working
groups so like the prompt engineering
working group who's who's focused is
much on like these prompting questions
uh and so
yeah i'm
one of the main offers like um
albert webster
colleen raffles stephen beckham like the
four main offers but i want to highlight
um a bunch of different offers you like
really like did an incredible job like
just like
sketching out a lot of things like
including the experiments like the
collection of prompts etc
um
so including like ling tang
um ling tang i know
um
[Music]
my roof um
just like a bunch of people like i'm
probably forgetting like
some of them like zaid antoine
kevin um yeah just like a very large
collaboration of like 40-ish different
authors
uh and of course like sasha rashford
like
was like crucial like in catching out
like the design and
like the whole paper
awesome uh can you explain the main
question you're asking the main idea of
the paper to
to start with
yeah um so we basically like started
like this endeavor by
just a fascination of
uh gpt3 and like the zero shot
capabilities um
objectivity free you know like
so jpd3 is kind of able to do
with a non-trivial performance a lot of
stuff in a zero-shot fashion right you
just give
a description of the task that you
are targeting and maybe like a couple of
priming examples so like pairs of x y
um
annotated x y that you
just want to do
um
and you you feed this description and it
is priming examples to gpt3 and like
it's able to do in a non-trivial fashion
performance like a lot of different
tasks like uh
question answering sentiment analysis
uh natural language inference like just
ton of tasks and for a long time we just
thought that it was
like in the community we thought that it
was impossible like just to get um this
kind of like zero shot um
zero technologies like at least
it wouldn't be it possible to get these
kind of preferences without any
supervising
um and so we kind of like started like
with this fascination and like very just
like
interest in this question of like
uh non-trivial performance on zero
attack and
to a certain extent these abilities in
jpg3 kind of like feels accidental in
the sense that um gp23 was mainly
trained on
um on just like a massive corpus of web
text right um
you put a massive model with a lot of
parameters a massive data set and you
train autoregressively so like the
losses like literally just for given
context predict the next word
and so like there is nothing like really
in this training signal that tells you
like to do like
zero or future learning here right
and so the question we want to ask you
in this paper is like can we
make these zeroshot abilities less
accidental right and so the research
question we're interested in is can we
induce like strong zero shot translation
by doing explicitly
multitask training like multi-task
learning
um and so what we what we did is um
we literally took a bunch of supervised
data set that were already public and
out there uh from the high interface
dataset library
and we prompted them so we created a
small
text templates that convert a supervised
data set and the examples in the
supervised data sets uh in know to take
into a text-to-text format so
a data set like in a simplified way
either pairs of x y
right um and we wrote uh some text just
to convert this x y pair
uh into a text exponent right so if you
take sentiment analysis for instance
then
uh the small function the text function
that convert in into a text format would
be
um is disproven negative or positive and
then you would feed the
review
and the model would be expected to
output uh like positive or negative
right the label
and so we we wrote just like a bunch of
prompts for this um for this supervised
data set um targeting like diversity of
tasks targeting diversity of prompts
and then uh from this collection of
prompted data set we train
massively multitask model so
we took like a
semi-giant model and train it um into
the texas tech format in the massively
multi-task pattern
and the main result is that um
we see like strong zero shot performance
and sometimes
quite often outperforming gpt3
like
on held out tasks so like tasks that
you've never seen during the training
i'll hand out hell that has really
outperformed gpt free um
while being 16 times smaller than gpt3
so when i talk about gpt3 i'm referring
to the full size model like the
175 billion parameters model and with
just a model of like 11 billion
parameters we get like
better performance on a set of hella
tasks in the zeroshot fashion
um and we have other results on big
bench with a similar conclusion um but
yeah like the the general idea of this
paper is just like you take a a bunch of
supervised dataset you prompt them
uh and you train a massively
multitask model on top of that to make
these little shot abilities less
accidental
and we kind of confirmed that in fusion
cool
when you say text to text i am reminded
of the t5 model actually not not like
gpe t3
uh
can can you talk about the difference
between t5 and t0 like what did you add
uh or improve on top of t5
yeah um so actually like the name t-zero
is like kind of a
play on words on top of it it's like
zero sharp t5 you know yeah it's uh t5
for zero shots so like we should kind of
like compress that into t0 um and so
like the whole story is that um
the
massive model that we took is actually
based on t5 so we took um
so we are we're not like
completely training from scratch record
fine tuning a pre-trained model and here
it's like t5 so to be very exact we took
the lm adapted version of t5 which is
like
um t5 was pre-trained with the denoising
objective right like you mask um
the encoder isn't is fed
uh with a sequence but with mass tokens
and the decoder is like trained to
generate the mass tokens so a denoising
objective
the lm adapted version
adds a few hundred thousand additional
steps of language modeling
so you given the context you predict the
next word
and so we took this
lm adapted version and fine-tune that um
into them
into the massively multitask setup
um
and so it's very much like inspired from
from the text to text format right like
this encoder decoder
setup can it like fits perfectly
our format where you have
just like the prompted examples and like
the recorder would output the target the
label
um
and so actually this text to text format
um
was actually introduced like before like
g5 um
like
papers like dknlp dknlp which is a
benchmark um
that cast a lot of different tasks into
this kind of framework of like text to
text format where you give just an input
to the model and you expect them all to
output generate the target the label
um
and so we kind of like go down this line
of like just convert everything into a
text format
feed the input generated target
um
also from what i get from the paper uh
the
the tasks you haven't
um you haven't really trained on they're
also achievable by the
with the zero shot capabilities
and you have made sure that those tasks
actually didn't exist in the pre-trained
t5 as well
so can you talk a little about that
because that's the most important
interesting part in my opinion
yeah
so
um we kind of did um a very like four
selection of the tasks that like uh
albert webster like led all this part
that like
he did a very forward selection of like
what tasks are we training on and what
task are we evaluating on and the idea
like is that
we really want to prove the the point on
zero shot test realization in the sense
that
if we want to claim any zero shot
performance then like we can't see the
stats um
in the training either like during the
fine tuning and hopefully not during the
pre-training
um
and so like in this hell path we have we
have selected like um
um things like natural language and
ferns like core reference
um i'm not forgetting like others but
that's kind of like the idea is like the
idea is that for humans like
easy to do this task um like because
like they're like natural language and
then they don't require expect knowledge
to
to perform
um and hopefully like the hope is that
one day like um just by giving a natural
instructions to a model like the model
would be able to perform the task in a
non-trivial way like with
performance that match the human
performance right
um
and so yeah like uh the hell that has
like include natural natural language
insurance coefficients and stuff like
that but also like the big bench
benchmark
which is a collection of
extremely funky uh
should i say
um funky tasks um
such as you know um
like logical puzzles like for instance
um
you have like to deduce
the order of like some objects like for
instance i give you like a bottle like i
have three books one red book one purple
book and one black one black book like
the black book
at the left of the red book
the black book is at the right of the
purple book and like what is the
leftmost book right
uh this is like the kind of like uh
tasks
that are in big bench
and we also saw like strong
um generalization performance on big
page
but
all these big bench tasks are like so
like funky
so like exeteric
that like we are absolute we are sure
that like they had never appeared in the
training like in the training we have
i would say quote
classical um nlp data set um such as
summarization question answering
sentiment analysis um
text classification but nothing as is
rhetoric as that right
um so we kind of like selected the
instead of training sets and instead of
held up held a task in the sense that
hopefully there won't be any overlap
between the two of them
it's it's actually quite cool
i'm usually not impressed uh from most
of the papers but i was seriously so
impressed about
the whole concept of training on
separate tasks and
not training on the specific
set of tasks and actually evaluating on
them because that's a huge
generalization and you actually trust
your model to do that
can you specify the the training and
validation sets here so you said in
validation that there's big bench
and there's nli and in the paper it's
actually said that as humans we don't
really we aren't trained on nli but we
do and alive by default and i i had a
pretty good laugh on it can you specify
the training and the validation sets
yeah um
so as i was saying like you know in the
training we have some virus of
compression entering we have um some
form of sentiment analysis summarization
uh topic classification um
we also have like paraphrase
identification so like um
one of one of these famous data that is
like the quora question pairs like you
have to identify whether or not
um two questions are kind of like the
same
have the same meaning
um
and yeah in terms of tests like we have
natural language interference criterions
words and disambiguation um which is
like the kind of a problem of like
for instance the word bank in english
kind of had like two meanings um either
you can mean like the financial
institution
or like the bank like
the river
uh so like it's given like a sentence
with the word bank inside and like you
have to decide whether that's like the
first meaning or the second meaning
um and other tasks like um
[Music]
sentence completion um
which which i
have like to decide
what's the best um
sentence ending uh for given premise
um and all these big bench um
big bench tasks like very funky one one
that i like a lot is the misconception
um
task which
is basically you have to decide like the
model has to decide whether
um
a given premise um
aligned with a common misconception
um and yeah so like these are like very
funky tasks and what's funny is that um
like when we release like the
inference widget uh when we release the
model on the hub on the hacking face hub
like people were actually also like
testing a bunch of like
other funky tasks
um and that was just like very funny
just to see like the imagination of like
people um
yeah
i actually really like that i talked to
teaser from time to time last time i
talked about it uh i i talked about dune
uh with t-zero and it was like um it was
quite
um i don't know how to say this i asked
about it about the villains and stuff
and it was quite rude but i was like you
get me you know
so um in the paper uh like in t5 they
are actually training with strict
prompts as far as i remember like you
have to say summarize this or
translate this
uh in the paper uh there is uh
you have you have written that uh there
is a
variety of prompts and you have actually
generated them so can you talk about
that
yeah
um
so
the the token um
i don't exactly remember how they call
it but uh the the prompts in t5 are like
kind of like a single token like maybe
two but like a really short kind of code
that indicates well what is the task
that you
that you expect the model to perform
um
we kind of took the next step which is
um like humans communicate in natural
language and like they write and talk
natural language right
um and they
explain things in natural language right
and
so that's why we
took to deliberate decisions of
writing prompts in full natural language
um and not just like
one or two tokens right
um
i think like this approach of one or two
tokens is very much related to
um
what people in the research committee
have been um
calling naming um
prompt tuning
which is um you basically give
one two three maybe ten i don't know
like but you give a sequence of like
fake tokens
uh and then you fine tune um the model
on top of that um
and
we are taking a kind of like almost
orthogonal approach here which is
that the which is the prompt should be
in full natural language
kind of almost an instruction so i'm not
saying any claim that the model right
now actually like really understands the
intrusion that we we're giving
but at least like
that's how we
that's like the premise to hand the hype
i wonder if if there is like a
generalization over that as well you
know like see understanding uh but it
hasn't seen as a prompt and actually
knowing that it is mapped to that prompt
you know have you ever tested that
to a certain extent yes um
so
we have experiments on that um basically
like
we
so the hybrid so what we see in gpt3 let
me give you a little bit of context is
that um jpeg and many other
models right
is that
um
the models are like very sensitive to
the prompt formulation so how you
basically ask your question
and sometimes it's like very much
observed right like you put a comma here
like you either put or not a comma here
and
you have a completely different
prediction
and this is like kind of like
the absurd behaviors that we want to
we want to mitigate um
right
ideally
like a
model would not be so sensitive to the
exact uh formulation of the prompt right
like if if you ask
is this review positive negative or
should be you should get similar result
as if you asked um
would you say that if we do positive
or negative
um right like you you should get like
the same performance but in practice
it's not really the case and we are also
seeing that kind of effect um in the in
the t0 paper where
the premise is that
variety and diversity will kind of help
the model to
um to be less sensitive to the
the prompt formulation
and our experiments suggest that in some
cases yes uh and in other cases not that
well right not that much so it's like
still very much an open question of
like what is a good prompt like how can
we just like increase this
robustness to the prompt formulation
it's like this is still very much like
an open research question of
yeah like how do we improve robustness
to deformitation
i actually saw
there was almost 2 000 something uh
prompts actually so i don't know um
how you can actually test with a prompt
that doesn't exist because there's
already too much
i guess well
you
so that's like kind of one of the
guideline that we designed when we did
the prompt collection is
you can think of
like we basically told like people who
were writing prompts like
try to be as diverse as possible and
just try to be like very creative in the
way that you formulate the prompt right
so if if you come back to the example of
a sentiment analysis then
um
then like
like a very easy prompt would be like is
this review positive but negative but
um a creative prompt in a sense would be
something like um i'm seeing this review
on
on amazon um
like
is
that this review indicate i should buy
them like i should
buy
the the product or not
another creative
problem would be um
is the
is the um
i don't know is the
customer satisfied with the product et
cetera
um
of like try to situate the situation so
that um you kind of like diversity in
that sense right
and so that was like a big emphasis of
like the
the prom collection going back to
previous question that was like a big
emphasis on diversity during the front
collection
because um
yeah like the main hypothesis is that
this kind of diversity would help um
will help the model and to
be more robust
um to
them
yeah to them
to the front formulation
and yeah we confirmed that like
intuition with the experience where we
can vary the number of prompts per data
set
so
we saw like these two effects of like
first
it kind of increases the performance
like the
average median performance but also kind
of like decreased
um
decreased um on average like the
the spread between the top performing
prompt and the lower performing problems
so in most of the cases we we saw that
but like in few other cases like
probably outliers that we didn't see
that effect
um
can you talk about the difference
between the variance of t 0 t 0 t 0 plus
and t zero plus plus
yeah
so
so that's funny um
let me just like share if any story
because like
when we pushed the models to the hub so
we wanted to call it like t0 plus plus
but you actually can't put a plus in the
name of the hub
so
like i replaced basically the plus by a
p and so some people are just like like
reading it by top and saying top rather
than t zero plus plus
and like retrospectively that's very
that's very unfortunate but yeah i'm
happy that you you say teaser plus um
so what are the difference between t0 to
0 plus and t0 plus plus so it's 19 like
the training sets
um like the only variation is really
like the training set that we are like
feeding to the model in the training
uh so t 0 is kind of like
um
almost like the baseline but in t0 plus
we added to the trading mixture
um
the gpt free evaluation data sets in gto
plus plus we added the gpt free of our
data set plus the super blue data sets
so
like the main difference is like the
number of um
training data sets that you feed to the
model during the functioning phase um
and so like the tzo plus plus just to
give you an order of magnitude
uh was trained on a mixture of like 50
around 50 data sets um and like the t0
the baseline almost uh was trained with
like around 30
35-ish data sets
cool
um
lastly like this is like my last
question and i'm going to ask you the
questions that i have received so far
um can you talk a little about the
potential improvements you might do over
t0
yeah
um
so this is the kind of like paper that
raised more questions that it answered
at the end
um
so i think we kind of like
verified the hypothesis that doing these
kind of like massively multitasked
training
um can we will induce a social
generalization
um
and another concurrent work that is
called
flan demolish called flan not the paper
but it's from the team at google
had a very similar conclusion right like
they diverse and they approached it
massively
they did they trained a very dodge model
on a massively much test setup
uh and so like
very similar um strong generalization
tests serious translation
uh so we cannot confirm the hypotheses
but like we also raised a bunch of other
questions so
if i continue in the comparison with
flan like one of the main difference
between t0 and flan is the size of the
model
one of the conclusion of the
the offers
from flan is that they
really see the strong uh task zero shot
performance
at a certain size right i think it was
like 140 ish billion parameters but we
saw um
we saw like strong improvements at only
11 billion kilometers
so i think there's like some experiments
we need to commit like really
understanding what like
what is driving this difference and why
do they need so much scale and just to
get the same difference so we have like
a transition around like maybe the
pre-training laws um
the exact architecture of the model but
like
that
we should do like we're conducting more
experiments around that right now
so very natural questions um a very
natural question after cheater is kind
of like um
can we extend um
the
can we extend these experiments to a
multilingual setup
especially
if you consider um languages where you
have lower resources right you have
less
fewer uh supervised data so how can we
just extend this approach to a
multilingual dataset not a lingual setup
um
another question that is very much open
right now is
basically doing analysis of like what is
a good prompt and what is a bad problem
right like so i told you about like this
question of robustness and
so even if when you kind of like
close the bit the gap like there's still
a gap between the top performing front
and the lower performing problems so
ultimately like ideally this gap would
be near to zero but it's still not um
zero so
um
there's a question of like yeah can we
characterize these lower
low performing prompt and high
performing problems and like what are
the difference what can we do to just
improve the low performing problem
and it's certainly like whether that's
on the front side or actually on the
modeling side right uh this is very much
an open question
um
[Music]
yeah and
yeah that's kind of like the the main
questions i have in mind right now um
but obviously like
it's raising um much more questions than
that and
hopefully by releasing like um
the collection of prompts and the model
like we're hopeful that it will kind of
foster
more research uh around around this um
and yeah hopefully like
it will kind of facilitate um
all these questions that are from
engineering
you have actually answered couple of
questions
by uh answering my question
so i'm going to only and ask one
question so one of the
one of the
uh people from the audience actually
asked
a question
i'm going to rephrase that so in gpt 3
and t 0 plus
when they fall into fallback they still
uh
give you the most likely answer instead
of saying
i don't know or this question does not
make any sense have you tried
doing
some kind of negative sampling where you
would create bogus question and or
questions with no way of answering based
on prompt expecting the output to be i
don't know or this doesn't make any
sense
yeah that's a good question um
so we thought about that we didn't end
up doing that explicitly as a way like
just to create more samples
um however like in
so not in t0 um
but actually in 202 but
so there are a couple of data sets um
i'm thinking for instance of squad v2
uh duo
rc
which actually contains this type of
question where
um
you basically don't have enough context
to answer so like
it's like
an answerable question basically right
like you have a you have a question and
you have a context but actually you
don't have enough information in the
context to answer the question you're
asking
and so we have said
we fed the model this kind of instances
during the
training um
and yet it's not really clear and we're
still kind of like analyzing this aspect
of what's happening here because
um even if we fed that to the training
um
the model is not
frequently or at least not as frequently
as we expect
outputting this kind of
um
i can't answer right
it should be
outputting and generating
uh this i can't answer or like this is
an answerable question like
around like i don't know ten percent of
the ten percent of the time in squad b2
i'm like coming up with this ten percent
that
that's the if it was perfect that it
would
output that ten percent of the time
right and it's actually not doing that
um
so this is kind of like the one of the
failure cases of
of t 0 t 0 plus n 0 plus plus is that
all these um
i call that calibration but like
to be very precise is like an ensemble
inputs
um
and yeah this is like
one of the failure cases that we don't
really understand that's probably coming
we have like a few hypotheses one of
them is that it's coming from like the
training mixture and like how you sample
the task
but we don't need to we may like to do
more investigation of that
you made it
i'm sorry
that was actually a very good question
and a very good answer to this i never
thought of that
i was i was previously doing chatbots
and we did have tons of fallback
mechanisms and stuff
so
um fedor is asking a question but this
is actually answered in the stream he
says
uh did you train t5 from a t0 from
scratch or did you find 25 it was
fighting on t5
uh the new trump engineering approaches
yes
yeah for me i should you should note um
next question financing but something i
should note is that um the performance
that we see with t0 plus plus like
basically all the variants
are still like very much behind
like the standard defined unit right um
so i think you can get like a very
strong performance just by taking
a bird large and fine tune just um on
nli right
uh but that's all that's
kind of like the upper bound of what we
could get like ideally
um and just like highlights how much we
still need like to to
to make progress like just like there's
a
big room for progress here
um
but that's almost like you know
two or three two of the real question
like the goal was not like just to
out to form like a standard functioning
was really like just to see
uh attach the original generalization
here
uh indeed that's what we have seen with
dpt3 they said you don't need to
fine-tune for anything anymore so
yeah
um thank you so much for uh coming i was
actually very um
amazed by the paper and it's a it's a
great uh
i really enjoyed our talk
uh we should do this more often i guess
yeah
no
next time uh i next time i'll have a
next time you have a paper then like are
you
are you going to
are you currently working on a paper by
the way which are you allowed to talk
about it
um yeah i mean like i'm allowed to talk
about like
what is happening to in big science like
since
it's very much like an open science
endeavor so like
i mean like everything you do is in the
open it's like everyone can check what's
happening but
um
just to give you an order of like
just to give you a few ideas
um
[Music]
we are kind of exploring the few
questions that um that i mentioned
earlier about like kind of like what we
do after g0
um
but like in general into big science
then we are like um converging to
having um
just a large multilingual data set um
covering very broadly each language and
kind of like the
each type of sources for these languages
um
and hopefully we will converge very soon
to just like training this massive
language model on this massive
multi-level data set
um yeah so that's kind of like
kind of like the work that is happening
right now um
and yeah hopefully there will be
artifacts that we can share uh so like
data set the
language model but also like
papers that analyze analyze these
these artifacts
awesome
uh our talk ends here because we don't
have any more questions uh have a nice
day to you i guess
thank you so much for having me that was
thank you so much for coming yeah that
was fun see ya
awesome have a great weekend